[Música]
la mifepristona seguirá disponible en
Estados Unidos luego de que la Corte
Suprema de Justicia de ese país
mantuviera el acceso sin restricciones a
esta píldora abortiva así no entran en
vigor las limitaciones al medicamento
que impusieron inicialmente tribunales
menores Aunque el presidente Joe biden
celebró la decisión la batalla legal
continúa
el mandatario Alberto Fernández no se
presentará a las elecciones
presidenciales de octubre en Argentina
en vez de buscar la reelección dice que
apoyará a algunos de los miembros de la
coalición frente de todos para llegar a
la casa rosada Tenemos reporte desde
Buenos Aires
el gobierno chileno de Gabriel boric le
apuesta a una mayor participación
estatal en la explotación de litio en su
país la nueva política nacional sobre el
llamado oro blanco pretende además crear
una empresa pública oficial para que
forjea alianzas con los privados
bienvenidos Estas son las noticias que
France 24 le dedica a América y yo soy
María Clara calle
iniciamos en Estados Unidos como lo
mencionábamos en los titulares la Corte
Suprema de Justicia decidió mantener por
ahora el libre acceso a la píldora
abortiva mifepristona el máximo tribunal
estadounidense lo que va así las
restricciones de tribunales inferiores
primero un juez de Texas declaró
inválida la aprobación que le dio la fda
al medicamento hace más de 20 años luego
el quinto circuito de apelaciones
mantuvo el acceso a la píldora pero con
ciertas restricciones y el viernes la
Corte Suprema de Justicia tumbó dichas
limitaciones sin embargo El quinto
circuito aún debe decidir sobre el caso
el reporte con todos los detalles lo
tiene Andrés triviño
por ahora el statu quo se mantiene la
Corte Suprema decidió mantener el libre
acceso a la píldora abortiva
mifepristona la orden detiene un fallo
de un juez Federal de Texas que
declaraba inválida la aprobación
otorgada del medicamento por la
administración de alimentos y
medicamentos fda hace más de dos décadas
el quinto circuito de apelaciones que
aún debe decidir sobre el caso dejó pie
para varias restricciones en el acceso a
la pastilla pero el pronunciamiento del
máximo tribunal supone un respiro de
alivio para los defensores de los
derechos reproductivos en Estados Unidos
hoy la Corte Suprema suspendió una
decisión que habría socavado el juicio
médico de la fda y pues en riesgo la
salud de las mujeres como resultado la
misión prehistona un fármaco aprobado
por la fda para el aborto con
medicamentos Sigue estando disponible y
aprobado
más que un simple tema de derecho
reproductivos el caso de la mifepristona
abre el debate sobre la autonomía de las
entidades científicas a la hora de tomar
decisiones sobre temas de salud y expone
el alcance de los grupos religiosos y
ultraconservadores en su deseo por poner
fin al aborto en el país la corte acaba
de mandar un mensaje claro
y es no se va a tomar una decisión como
estas de una forma ligera si bien
sorprende que los jueces alito y los
jueces tomas tuvieran como una un voto
disidente sobre esta decisión igual te
muestra que no es un caso de aborto
común y corriente sino es un caso que
tiene implicaciones que van muchísimo
más grandes junto con el misoprostol la
mifepristona es uno de los dos
medicamentos que se usan en los abortos
farmacológicos la combinación es capaz
de interrumpir el embarazo casi con un
100% de efectividad y es usada en más de
la mitad de los abortos en el país Desde
que la Corte Suprema derogara el
histórico falloud versus White 13
estados de la mayoría republicana han
impuesto prohibiciones a la interrupción
del embarazo y otras más serias
restricciones
el presidente de Argentina Alberto
Fernández anunció que no buscará la
reelección en los comicios generales del
próximo octubre en el video que publicó
en sus redes sociales agregó que sí
trabajará para que algún Aliado suyo del
peronismo sea elegido previamente desde
Buenos Aires nuestro corresponsal
natario nos explicó si esta noticia era
sorpresiva o no en Argentina y cuáles
podrían ser los posibles candidatos del
frente de todos él llegó a la
presidencia no como un candidato que se
había lanzado solo por cuenta propia por
su deseo personal sino por decisión de
la vicepresidenta Cristina Fernández de
kirchner expresidenta de la nación ella
fue la que anunció la candidatura de él
como presidente y ella como Vice Y
muchos dicen aquí que la idea de una
posible reelección de Alberto Fernández
de una candidatura de reelección de
Alberto Fernández siempre fue algo poco
claro él nunca lo había dicho
explícitamente Ahora no dijo
explícitamente que renunciado en el
video de casi 8 minutos en el que
difundió esta decisión sino que habló de
que le tras las le traspasará la banda
presidencial cuando sea decidido Quién
es el próximo presidente de Argentina el
10 de diciembre próximo sobre los
candidatos es muy difícil está débil la
coalición en algún punto tras varios
años de ser gobierno y eso además es el
gobierno del medio de la pandemia y con
las dificultades económicas que
atraviesa el país y hay algunos nombres
en danza ninguno definitivo algunos
hablan del ministro de economía Sergio
massa él Hasta ahora ha dicho que no que
no está pensando en eso otros dentro de
la coalición hablan del gobernador de la
provincia de Buenos Aires axeló Pero él
dice que prefiere ir hasta donde sabemos
a una reelección como gobernador hay
otros nombres en danza también guado de
Pedro Eduardo guado Pedro que es
ministro del interior algunos están
hablando Agustín Rossi que es jefe de
gabinete Les estoy dando varios nombres
Daniel scioli también que es el actual
embajador en Brasil hay falta de
definición realmente ese es el problema
que por ahí tiene ahora se puede decir
el frente de todos
chile quiere ser el primer productor de
litio en el mundo así lo expresó el
presidente Gabriel borich al revelar la
política nacional sobre el llamado oro
blanco como parte de la directriz el
mandatario propuso crear la empresa
Nacional del litio que aunque será
Estatal La idea es que pueda asociarse
con privados si bien actualmente de
chile es el segundo productor mundial de
litio detrás de Australia es en otra
medida el país con más reservas una
posición relevante ya que el litio es la
base de las baterías recargables que
sustentan la transición energética por
eso boricci la apuesta a su crecimiento
protegiendo la nacionalización de litio
que fue declarada desde 1979 escuchemos
cuando hablamos de desarrollo estamos
pensando en el bienestar para los
habitantes de nuestra patria no para
unos pocos estamos pensando en que la
riqueza que existe en nuestra en nuestro
territorio sea mejor distribuida
descentralizadamente
la Industria Del litio tiene que estar
al servicio de las personas y no las
personas al servicio de una industria el
nivel del mar ha aumentado más de 10
centímetros en todo el mundo desde la
década de los 90 según el más reciente
informe de la Organización meteorológica
Mundial el derretimiento de los
glaciares es la principal causa de este
incremento a la vez que los océanos
registran un récord de calor que hacen
cada vez más difícil la vida para miles
de especies Samuel Salgado nos cuenta
qué dice el reporte
el aumento del nivel del mar por el
cambio climático llegó a un punto de no
retorno según la ONU
desafortunadamente estas tendencias
negativas en los patrones climáticos
pueden continuar hasta 2060
independientemente de nuestro éxito en
la mitigación del cambio climático
más de 10 centímetros ha aumentado el
nivel del mar desde la década de 1990 y
sólo entre 2013 y 2022 los niveles
globales aumentaron a del doble del
Ritmo que lo hicieron en la primera
década de mediciones entre 1993 y 2002
las principales causas del aumento son
el derretimiento de los glaciares y los
niveles récord de calor en los océanos
por la acumulación de dióxido de carbono
en la atmósfera entre otros gases de
efecto invernadero el cambio climático
es una realidad y su impacto se siente
cada vez más dicen estos activistas
liderados por extinción rebelión y
greenpeace frente al parlamento del
Reino Unido en Londres exigiendo al
gobierno que detenga las nuevas
licencias de exploración de petróleo y
gas y que Escucha la ciencia cuando voy
a India a visitar a mis padres se siente
como meter la cabeza en el horno hace 48
grados a veces 50
y cuando camino por Londres me siento
como en una especie de película
distópica
El día de la tierra llega luego de
semanas de clima extremo con
temperaturas que alcanzaron un récord de
grados Celsius en Tailandia y produjeron
olas de calor en India dejando al menos
13 personas muertas la Organización
meteorológica Mundial y el grupo
intergubernamental de expertos sobre el
cambio climático prevén que este año
podría registrarse un nuevo récord de
altas temperaturas por el inicio del
efecto del niño superando al verano de
2022 que pasó a la historia como el más
caluroso en Europa desde que se tienen
registros
hasta aquí las noticias los invitamos a
que consulten más información
internacional en France 24.com y en
nuestras redes sociales con arroba
franz24 raya al piso es Gracias por
elegirnos
[Música]